Machiavelli was a very smart guy who by
the way wrote the prince in the hope of
attracting employment he failed to get
the job he was a little too nice
not quite tough enough so you know most
people who are familiar with Machiavelli
are familiar with the views he expressed
in the prince not so many people seem to
have read his discourses where he
thought that the best form of government
is a more republican form of government
that is a democracy and our modern terms
and while I certainly agree that from
the perspective of the folks on the
street it's far in a way the best form
of government from the perspective of a
leader somebody who wants to hold on to
power it's the worst form of government
because it puts you at the greatest risk
of losing power so in the dictators
handbook we go well beyond Machiavelli's
understanding to lay out precisely what
leads you to hold on to power and
precisely what ties the hands of a
Democrat and trying to do the things
that dictators also do let's start with
what the five rules of politics are
first you want to depend on as few
people as possible to keep you in power
I'm going to come back to that because
it ties very closely to the second
second you want the pool of people you
could call upon to fill the role of that
small group to be at that pool to be as
large as possible that way the folks who
are in the small group to keep you in
power know that if they are wayward if
they begin to back somebody else or
they're not willing to do the things
that you the leader asked them to do
they know they're easily replaced often
especially journalists make the mistake
of looking at rigged election systems
such as Lenin introduced in the Soviet
Union and mistakenly believing that
somehow because there are elections this
confers legitimacy that's a very silly
idea because after all everybody already
knows the outcome of the election before
it happens so how could it be legitimate
the function of having universal
suffrage in a rigged system is exactly
to signal the folks in in the
Circle the people you're rewarding that
hey you are easily replaced you better
do what I want
third rule so you've got a smaller group
as possible drawn from the as bigger
pool as possible you want to tax the
people as highly as you can because you
want revenue to enrich yourself and to
bribe your cronies taxing the people as
highly as you can there are two
constraints you don't want to tax so
much that people prefer taking siestas
to doing work because the objective of
the tax of course is to generate money
for you if the people aren't working
then they're not going to generate money
for the leader and second you want to
don't want to tax to the point that
people calculate that you know things
are so bad I might as well revolt I
can't be worse off so you want to tax as
much as possible as long as people keep
working and don't revolt you want to
distribute the minimum amount of that
revenue that you can get away with to
keep your coalition loyal to you not by
not deciding to back somebody else and
the reason you want to give them as
little as you can subject to the
constraint that they not join somebody
else is you want as much of the money
left over for your own discretion as
possible and with the money that you
need to use to keep your coalition loyal
you don't want to be spending that money
instead on benefiting the the people
because the people don't keep you in
office and rewarding the coalition how
do you reward them well there are
basically two ways to reward people you
can produce good public policy that's in
technical terms a public good it's
something that everybody gets to enjoy
or you could be producing private
rewards just to the coalition the the
key difference in what Democrats and
dictators do is that Democrats much to
their regret have to depend on a very
large coalition to keep them in power
it's just too expensive to bribe
millions of people with private rewards
so Democrats are compelled by their
desire to stay in power to produce good
public policy
the smaller the coalition the more
efficient it is to buy loyalty with
private goods instead of public goods
all leaders produce private goods it's
just a question of the relative mix of
private and public the bigger the
coalition the more public goods the
smaller the coalition the mix favors
private goods now leaders may have
revenue leftover if they have a small
coalition they pay just enough they may
have money left over at their discretion
and there are basically two things they
can do with that money they can sock it
away in a secret bank account very
popular with the world's kleptocrats or
they could be civic minded now when you
depend on a small coalition and your
civic minded you as well divide Kressley
put into two groups so you might be
somebody like Lee Kuan Yew in Singapore
or dong Xiao ping in China who has
really good ideas about how to spend
money to build an economy and might make
the folks of the country well-off on the
other hand you might be Mao Zedong the
old Soviet leader Nikita Khrushchev the
old Ghanaian leader Kwame Nkrumah he
stole a bit but most of these guys
didn't steal nearly as much as they
could have they seem to have been civic
minded they seem to have wanted to
improve the welfare of their citizens
but they had remarkably bad ideas about
how to go about doing it and so they
made their citizens worse off one of the
nice features of democracy of depending
on a large coalition is the leader can't
wander very far from what a significant
number of voters want and so policy is
less variable more predictable growth
rates aren't higher but they're steadier
those are the five rules of governance
you